fois qu'on a payé de factures il nous
reste huit euros pour vivre hausse de la
csg gel des retraites changement de
calcul des pensions le niveau de vie des
retraités
c'était mieux avant et bien c'est plus
compliqué avant de commencer un peu de
pédagogie d'accord là dessus pour savoir
si les retraités sont à l'aise ou pas
financièrement l'insee calcule leur
niveau de vie relatif en le comparant
avec le reste de la population et les
walis exemple avec les années 70 à cette
époque les retraités sont à 70 % du
niveau de vie relatif par rapport au
reste de la population
concrètement lorsque les français
gagnent 100 euros les retraités eux
gagne 70 euros petite pension veuve
n'ayant jamais travaillé
les retraités sont extrêmement
vulnérables et vous arrivez à vivre
parler s'ils arrivent à vivre on arrive
à comment on peut penser mais est-ce que
vous avez pleuré
aulnoye qui pas parce que j'ai
permettrait plus que à partir des années
70 la vie des retraités s'améliorent
entre 1970 et 1986
les pensions de base et complémentaires
augmentent de 11,4 pour cent par an
conséquence le niveau de vie des
retraités augmente
alors dès le début des années 80
certains acteurs économiques sentent le
bon filon le club méditerranée a été
jusqu'à changer ses publicités pour
s'assurer leur clientèle campagne 84
jolies filles sur sable fin campagne 85
monsieur chenu en pleine santé mais
chose est un peu ventru en 1996 le
niveau de vie des retraités dépasse même
celui du reste de la population
une nouvelle économie émerge alors la
silver economy l'économie argenté
faisant référence aux cheveux des
seniors l'avantagent qu'on en tire à
servir cette clientèle
c'est qu'ils voyagent déjà en basse
saison
d'où ils obtiennent de tarifs très
intéressants et il faut reconnaître que
nous agences de voyages pendant la basse
saison
nous aussi en dix ans ce spécialiste
dans cette clientèle ça nous permet
aussi de maintenir et voire d'augmenter
nos chiffres d'affaires mais le climax a
été atteint car depuis 1996 le niveau de
vie des retraités stagne et pour les
petites pensions le quotidien reste
toujours compliqué restaurant n'a pas
les vacances on n'a pas les retraités
sont pas si lundi que seuls et le temps
des retraités nantis semble bien
terminée car selon les projections du
conseil d'orientation des retraites un
organisme gouvernemental
le niveau de vie relatif des retraités
va baisser en cause les pensions sont
maintenant calculée sur l'inflation et
non plus sur les salaires qui
progressait plus vite
[Musique]